Hey it's me Destin. So I feel like I owe you an apology for not making videos the last
couple of weeks but when I explain why I hope you will accept my apology. So it started like this.
I got something in the mail.
Turns out it is the new Phantom camera.
It's called a Miro M320S. So this is different.
It's a lot smaller, it's more sensitive, it's better than what I've been shooting with in the past,
and they're letting me try it out. There's only a few of these in the continent right now. So Miro is
Spanish for "I see", so it's kind of like "Hey I see something that
I haven't seen before", so I thought that was a pretty cool name. I took this over
9000 miles on 8 different plane trips to meet all kinds of cool people all over the country
to shoot video for you. So in a nutshell the reason I haven't been showing you videos,
is because I've been shooting videos. So it started like this. I got on a plane and
I went out west, and I met a guy named Alan Sailer. Alan Sailer is "the man"
when it comes to high speed photography but he doesn't know a lot about high speed video.
So Alan combined what he knew and his artistic style with what I know
as a high speed video guy, and we made some really cool videos. That'll be coming
up soon. After that in the desert a guy named Greg came out
and met me to show me a device that he had built, and we analyzed that and looked at all the math involved
in how that thing worked. That's gonna be cool as well. After that I went out
of my way a little bit and went and saw my buddies Joe and Buzz.
Buzz bought me an ice cream sundae with USA drawn across it in chocolate syrup.
Of course we shot a bunch of cool video and that was that. After that I got back on
a plane and went to the Perimeter Institute for Theoretical Physics in Waterloo Canada
to a meeting called BrainSTEM. BrainSTEM, STEM meaning Science
Technology Engineering and Math. At BrainSTEM I met some really cool people. I met Chris from
Science Alert in Australia. I saw Michael from Vsauce again. I met Vihart
who makes math videos on YouTube. I saw Derek from Veritasium we got to shoot
some slinky footage together. I also saw Henry from Minute Physics in his office.
He showed me how Minute Physics works, that was fun. He also plays the
violin and the mandolin, so we shot some really cool video of that. I was
also able to do a demonstration of high speed video using liquid nitrogen and fruit
provided by the faculty of the Perimiter Institute. They use their liquid
nitrogen for their superconducters, so I was able to use it for a less noble purpose
but it's pretty awesome.
[bang] Nice.
[laugh]
I flew back to LA and I went to VidCon.
VidCon is this big huge meeting of a bunch of people from YouTube basically. It was fun.
I got to sit on a Physics panel with Henry from Minute Physics and Derek
of Veritasium, that was pretty cool. They got to ask them questions about theoretical physics
I answered all the really hard questions about snack cake design and stuff like that. I setup
a high speed camera and I let people just walk up and experience high speed on their own.
I didn't really officially get a booth but I found a spare outlet, and they
tried to run me off once or twice but I just kinda stuck to it. But it was fun.
Destin, hotel, LA.
Gavin, slow-mo guy.
Hello. So, you brought a high speed camera to me..
(Destin) Pretty much, yeah.
Which is awesome, cause I don't have one at the moment.
So we've gotta come up with stuff to do in this regular hotel room.
So I bought this shirt to wear to VidCon. I thought it'd be pretty good. I found it at a thrift store
in Arizona. Anyway it's a really adorable kitty cat and I thought hey it's YouTube,
they would love kitty cats. But the problem is I chickened out. In hindsight
I made a foolish decision, I should have worn the kitten shirt. I've been compiling all this video, so
that's why I haven't released a video. I'm preparing for the future. Speaking of prepare for the future,
I put a link on the main channel page that you can directly
donate to my kids scholarship. I call it a micro scholarship. That's really why I shoot
Smarter Every Day is to raise money for my kids college education and I'm serious about that.
Thank you to the five people that just happened to find the link and donate. Thank you very much.
Ooh, rubber band just popped. I'm gonna leave you with this. I want to introduce you to a guy named
Brady Haran. So he went to both BrainSTEM and VidCon and we became
very close over the entire week. But the thing is, we became so close that
we started picking on each other, you know, that kind of friend? So here's what I want to do.
I want to introduce you, the viewing audience of Smarter Every Day to Brady's videos but I decided to make
him earn it. So here's the deal. I setup a challenge using the Miro
and Brady had to earn the right to have you link to his
stuff, and hopefully subscribe. This is kinda how that went down.
My business card is not as impressive as yours Destin, but this is it.
This is the world's smallest periodic table
which has been etched on a human hair. It's in this year's Guinness Book of Records,
you can look it up, and of course it's also on one of our videos on Periodic Videos.
(Destin) OK so here's the deal. Brady makes
a channel called Periodic Videos at the University of Nottingham, and if you
watch Smarter Every Day you probably have figured out by now I'm pretty weak in chemistry
but this man and his team is probably the strongest channel in chemistry
and I think you should pretty much go check it out. But for now, before I give
them a link, I'm gonna make you earn it. I want to teach you..
(Brady) I'm I'm
singing for my supper am I?
(Destin) Yes you are. So I want you to set this mousetrap.
So let's figure this out.
(Brady) Can I, like, you know how we were joking
around saying I don't know how to set a mousetrap? I actually don't know how
to set a mousetrap, so you just giving it to me and saying set it is kind of..
This is Smarter Every Day man, I've seen your videos, your videos teach the smartest things in the world
and here we're learning how to set a mousetrap. I think you're lowering the tone.
(Destin) Put your thumb right here and don't move it.
Yeah.
(Brady) Is that done it?! ohh!
(Destin) I have the high speed camera
and we were gonna do the mousetrap right?
-yeah
(Destin) I wanna see if you can
trip that with your finger without getting hit.
- And what do I
get in return for this?
(Destin) I'll provide a link to your Periodic
Videos. [laugh] Deal?
- And and
like.. oh well, alright. I have a lot of respect
for your viewers and if a few of them come to Periodic Videos I think it's worth a broken finger.
(Destin) You won't break a finger if you're fast enough. [laugh]
[snap] Ooh.
(Brady) Is that the pen bending?
(Destin) 12.161. OK if you can
get out of the way in about 90ms you're good.
(Brady) Man I can't even think that fast. Alright you want me to do it?
(Destin) Yeah go.
[laughs]
That was like a.. that was a practice golf swing.
[snap]
(Destin) Yeah you got it! Way to go!
Alright, so.. Brady has successfully
earned your trust, so if you want to go see Periodic Videos
and a really adrenaline pumped Brady then
click on the link here, and go check out his videos.
He actually has
a lot of channels, so if you can calm down enough to tell me what you got.
Periodic Videos for chemistry, Sixty Symbols for
physics, I mean I've just displayed some physics skills there, and there's
Deep Sky Videos for people that like astronomy like Destin, there's some good space stuff.
And Numberphile is a really good one for some numbery maths stuff as well.
They're all at the University of Nottingham for the most part but he does things like go to Everest, I mean it's really
top notch stuff. So go check it out, I'm Destin you're getting Smarter Every Day
Brady's getting more manly every day. [laugh] Have a good one. Later.
Yeah, stupider every day.
[laugh]
[ Captions by Andrew Jackson ]
captionsbyandrew.wordpress.com
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.